i think this is a good strategy you say
no to most everything then when you see
the thing that you're like
this is it you go 100 all in on it
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
all right we're live you you didn't know
enough about red ventures to bring that
up
uh i talked to somebody who sold their
company to red ventures
and they were telling me about it and i
was like oh i just made a note i was
like
fascinating gotta go research more so i
put it on here just to be like i'm gonna
go research more and then you added
i know a lot in all caps so you already
know a lot which is great
maybe we we can talk about later also
another thing that i actually forgot to
add this i was watching the ufc
fight and do you remember about
four weeks ago maybe two weeks ago we
discussed this business of giving away
like cars
and you have to um i saw an ad
at the bottom of the ufc fight and i
think that like one way that i find
ideas is anyone who's doing brand
advertising so there's two types of well
i guess there's many types of
advertising but there's the first type
is performance which is
uh you click on something and i could i
could see 100
when you purchased and i could see
everything about that and i could like
attribute
it's it's attribution market marketing
performance marketing is what it's
called
the second is brand marketing so like
billboards or what's another example i
don't even know yeah just tv commercials
right you do a commercial you don't know
necessarily and they try to measure it
but in reality budweiser when they run a
commercial at the super bowl it's
because they're trying to build
awareness they want budweiser to be top
of mind maybe they want to talk about
their
zero calorie beer they're just trying to
build awareness and they're not directly
hoping that you
watch that open up your phone by
budweiser right that moment that's not
the way that that
that marketing is designed they hope
that you eventually walk into the store
and it influences you this is what geico
does
and often early early-stage companies
particularly tech companies who are like
savvy with internet marketing
start with performance and then when
they exhaust that then they go all right
now like we need to like just we just
need more people in the world to know
about this product and so what i love
doing is
i like looking at who's doing brand
advertising because
not always but often that means that
they're like crushing it
yeah it's like buying art if you're
buying art you're rich if you're buying
brand ads your
company's rich yes that's a great
example and i
saw uh ufc they had this ad for watch
gang
and i think watch game may be sponsored
in an embedded episode but then also
like before one of the fights it said
this episode is brought to you by
watch gang getting a rolex every month
and i was like what is going on with
that what is that i've never heard of
watch gang
and i know a little bit about watchers
or at least i'm a fan and
so i don't want to i even though i am
kind of bringing it up but i don't want
to get into it too much but they were
doing i went to watchking.com and they
were doing a contest
for a rolex giveaway rolex yeah
this so my co-worker at twitch uh when i
was there
he um he came up to me he shows me his
watch and i'm like hey man nice watch
he's like i got this in this uh this
watch club that i'm in
so tell me more and he tells me about
watch gang and he's like yeah i found
this website i had no idea if it's a
scam or not
he's like it's crazy this watch is like
a 250 watch and i'm paying 30 bucks a
month like i don't really understand
every month they send me another watch
and i was like
i was like okay it sounds fishy like
he's like yeah exactly so i didn't even
know if anything would come but like
look at this it's here
and um and so then i went and played
with it and it's like one of these like
super
optimized websites it's like you you
open up the website
bam let me get your email for this thing
oh you don't want the email spin the
wheel and win some more
oh you spun the wheel okay you have 30
seconds to finish your checkout or else
you're gonna like
your family will be taking ransom and so
it's like this like and if you go to it
it's just like
one hero image and then it's like uh you
know the tagline basically is
uh you know get new watches sent right
to your door do you keep them you sure
do
are the watches good no sir they're
amazing right so it's like
well-written copy huge hero image i'm
like this site prints money
and so i just made a mental note about
watch gang at that moment and it's like
a mystery box like you don't know which
watch you're gonna get you might get one
of those thousands of dollars watches or
you might get the like hundred dollar
watch but you're always getting a watch
of good value
and the weird thing is who needs this
many watches i don't know nobody needs
12 watches a year as far as i'm
concerned but maybe i'm just not the
demo yeah so when i see this stuff
like if you're in the internet long
enough which you know it's not that you
don't need to do it that much
in order to see that when you see
something like this you're like
something is going on to where
it's maybe a scam and full of it but
also like
if you told me this made 200 million
dollars i would be like yeah yeah i
totally buy it
it's an arbitrage place so it's the same
way that like um
you know most of the d2c brands they're
not like truly making the best products
but they're like look if we're really
good at facebook marketing or if we're
really good at affiliate marketing or
really good at whatever influencer
marketing then we could build like
movement watches they built 100 million
dollar plus
luxury watch brand in two years they
made it sound like a
old school brand they you know they
partner with all these influencers they
use this
market it's a marketing company not a
watch company really
and so that's what this is for sure this
is a marketing company not a watch
company they could swap this out and do
this with golf clubs
they could do this with shoes they could
do this with whatever you could just you
could take this watch gang website and
you could do it with sneakers right now
and i think you would do pretty well i
think there's something with that there
must be something where they're getting
the watches you know super discounted
somehow like
these might be like out of style watches
or refurbished or some i don't know what
they're doing
but there has to be some way that
they're able to give you this watch
and still make money in the something
what i don't know if it's 30 bucks still
or
i don't know how much this i don't know
why i i saw the ad whenever i see people
advertising on the ufc
i think uh they're like there's a lot of
new brands like manscaped advertisers
there and
i had heard of manscape and then they
advertised in the ufc i'm like oh they
they must be monsters they're
so you have to be okay with your logo
getting covered in blood
and i think most brands just don't want
that and then the brands that
were okay with that got this big upside
of a huge amount of eyeballs for a very
low
uh very low ad cost and so early on
you know it looked like nascar every
fighter would come out and they'd have
like 50 logos of like from their mom and
pop like
barber shop in their local town to like
you know some random
insurance company or uh you know energy
drink or whatever and they've been
trying to get it more and more
mainstream although
they just announced 175 million dollar
deal with crypto.com
is crypto.com scammy or legit i don't
know anything about it
well they offer eight percent uh return
eight percent cash back
so that's how you know it's uh it's
probably not totally uh
uh it's not that it's a scam it's again
it's like
these sort of hand-wavy types of things
it's like yeah you get our crypto card
it's a metal card
it's awesome and then when you spend you
earn eight percent
in crypto bucks say wait what's a crypto
book that's our own currency we created
it's like oh god it's like you got to
hold 5000 crypto bucks and then you earn
the eight percent
it's like uh dude do i want to go buy
five thousand dollars of your crypto
buck in order to earn the eight percent
here i don't know i don't think so
yeah they they let a lot of stuff like
that and and advertise with them but um
i want to bring up a couple topics you
have a few ideas but you
talked about this house thing so i want
to ask you about that um
yeah first time since covid we went to
uh vegas
and i'm staying in a house uh i'm
staying with somebody and their house is
unbelievable dude i am like like a
family member
this is somebody i'm related to yes so
this is this is a house that's
i think it's worth like probably 15
million dollars and 50 million dollars
in san francisco we'll give you a fat
house 50 million dollars in vegas
let's give you what what i mean i'm in a
resort i'm in a personal resort
like i was walking in and i was like
trying to not trip into the koi ponds
along the way just to the door door
opens up there's a freaking you know
from the hotel that little what the bell
man has that cart
to take your [__] to your room they have
one of those because the room is so far
away from the door because they're just
so big of a house
and so i use that i get to my room my
room is like you know
everything's magical dude we were eating
dinner and then all of a sudden like a
convertible the roof
retracted from over our heads the walls
disappeared they went away and then we
all went swimming in this pool that
surrounds
the dining room while looking out at
downtown vegas it's unbelievable
and the reason i say this is because i
thought i knew how much money i wanted i
thought i'd do what i wanted and now
that i've stayed in this house
i'd like some more money please that's
that's my brutally
honest feeling my raw emotion that i
have 24 hours into this house is
oh [__] this okay yeah i can be happy
without this
but why can't i do this too this is this
is pretty nice i've never seen how much
do you think you need to have
to have a 15 million dollar house what
do you think your your like investable
asset like
relatively liquid net worth needs to be
like 60 70. i think 100 to be safe
70 if you're 60 70 if you're uh like
50 60 i guess if you're if you're just
kind of like playing it you're you're
comfortable with it being riskier i
guess or like
if that 50 60 that you have is not
totally at risk you could say oh okay
you know i've
got that cashed out i'm gonna put it in
safe investments and 15 million i'll put
into my house
um this house was previously owned by
somebody who's like kind of
what their grandfather started like
caesar's or one of the casinos two of
the casinos downtown
and so it's like a billionaire family
and they sold the house to these guys
and then they
uh and then actually the funny thing is
they sold the house
uh and then they regretted it as soon as
they sold it to them the day later they
were like
hey you know the broker calls broker
says my client really regrets selling
that house
oh no and it was one person living here
so it was like this it's this enormous
like you know 30 car garage bowling
alley type of thing i don't know if
there is i haven't even explored the
whole house yet i've only seen like
one-fourth of the house so far but um
she called back i'll give you a million
dollars extra in cash
just to have the house back one day
later and they turned it down
dude i think that's cool i i love
visiting that in my head i think
i actually don't want that maybe maybe
it's because if you're wealthy enough
to buy that then you just have people
who could take care of it but when i
think of owning something
uh that expensive and that nice i'm like
oh my gosh i need to take care of it
yeah that sounds like a lot of work uh i
think that's true for most things i feel
differently about a house
for two reasons one is i think a house
like this makes sense
when you have what they have like tons
of kids basically so you have
you have like a full family uh right
they have four kids and it's like
um this is your family's compound it's
like this is your home base your kids
like
you kind of you wouldn't really do this
i don't think if you're a bachelor if
you're a bachelor you want to be
you know penthouse in manhattan or
something cool like that but this is
different this is like
it's a suburban home right but it's like
a family compound so i think that's the
first
thing the second thing is a yacht
or like cars those are like low
use high maintenance whereas a house is
like tremendously high use
and actually quite low maintenance for
for most homes because
for you know they have a cleaning staff
they have like people that can come take
care of stuff and yeah there's bills i'm
not saying there's no bills i guess what
i'm saying is
it's not like a car where you're worried
about getting scratched when it goes out
when you go park it anywhere and you're
driving anywhere and most of the time
it's just sitting idle
unused in a garage with a tarp on top in
this case for a house you're constantly
in it you're constantly using it
especially if you have a big family so
i would say house is the one area where
i would splurge
uh almost every other material
possession like fancy clothes cars
it just doesn't make sense to me when i
hear about people like this i always
the same question pops up in my head
which is how much should they spend per
month
so if you had to guess this person's
total family
uh expenses including the house what
would you guess it i imagine
you get a mortgage on it you get a
mortgage on a 15 million dollar house
like
like randy moss said straight cash baby
they had they had to
in order to get the house they had to
like go in oh my gosh so you don't have
a mortgage on the house normally a
mortgage i mean
what they do is they can finance it
afterwards so they buy it in cash and
then they'll go
and they'll refinance it basically get
they'll cash out you know
they'll leave 30 down and then they'll
take the other 70 they'll pay
you know some percentage but for this
you can't even get a traditional
mortgage for this
yeah you get like a rich perspective so
they got like a
hard money loan basically if they wanted
to cash it out or okay so including that
let's not include that that's hard to
conclude yeah because that's even hard
to calculate i don't even know what that
i mean that could be like 100 a month
i don't know what it would be that's a
lot but
life expenses not including the house
which is a
a ton yeah i would not be surprised if
it was between a hundred and two hundred
thousand dollars a month that'd be my
no i wouldn't be surprised i wouldn't be
surprised that's so much money to spend
it could be a little less could be 70.
it's definitely not less than 50. it's
my guess i'll ask you today i'll find
out
where that's always that's a good
question um she's like what's your burn
yeah exactly what's your burn that's a
good question so
let me tell you really quick and uh so
this house
this there's a lot next to my house that
i mean you know that little crappy
shack that was next to my house yeah
it's for sale
i think i'm gonna buy it and i'm gonna
build a house there and
try to sell it or rent it out and i'm
excited to do this and
i'll talk about this on this podcast i'm
excited to do it because i've never done
a project like this i've never done like
a physical business really
i've only done uh you know digital stuff
and i think it's gonna be exciting do
you think that's a stupid idea or a
smart idea
no i think it's a smart idea because
it's gonna like kind of change the way
you look at the world a little bit
and it's right next to you if this was
like even two miles away i'd be like nah
dude it's just a headache
when it's literally right next to you
that takes a lot of the like
overhead of managing a project or even
thinking about a project
or researching whether there's a good or
bad buy it's like okay what's the worst
case scenario
you're gonna have a house next to the
house you have you already like this
neighborhood you already like being
there your friends are all there
you're going to be able to like airbnb
this with low maintenance because it's
right next door you know you'll never
have to worry about it
and uh your friends can come crash there
when it's not rented out
um or you can like expand to it if you
build your dream house right you can
build your dream house right next to you
which is a fun fun project to do for you
and sarah and uh then maybe you leave
your house you go to that house if you
like build it for it takes a year to
build or whatever
so i think it's a great idea um and it's
not like it's not about it's not a
financial idea in my opinion it's a
it's a life idea it's a it's a fun thing
to do that will probably break even to
be profitable
when you do it what i'm learning uh
about finances
is that you know you and i talk about
investing in different stuff
you can just just your average joe has
access to this as well so this isn't
like
there's just if you just park it into a
general
fund like a general index fund life is
so easy and you get
almost amazing returns like compared to
everything else
do you know what i mean like it's so
easy you don't have to well you need a
big base right that's the problem for
most people yes that that vehicle is
available for most people but let's say
you're getting seven percent a year
you put a hundred thousand dollars in
okay cool you made seven thousand
dollars
pre-tax right now you have 107 000. you
need to let that [__] compound for like
20 years and like charlie munger once
said when they asked him what hey
your guys's playbook seems pretty simple
why don't more people do it he said
no one wants to get rich slow i think
that's the problem is that nobody wants
to take a small base and let it compound
for 20 years or very few people do and
that's that's the issue there
yeah it is it's boring but it works and
then um
i want to bring up one quick topic i met
three interests two three interesting
people this week so i think people like
hearing this i enjoyed hearing this
about this
15 million house all right i met this
guy named jason have you ever heard of
this company called block works
block works no is this like a
construction company no
it's right up your alley it's a media
it's basically like the hustle like
morning brew
like axios but for crypto oh okay
i think it's blockworks.io maybe dot co
maybe oh is it dot co um so block works
it's this guy bootstrapped he's only 27
years old i went to his house last night
in new york
uh in brooklyn awesome business probably
will do
eight figure yeah maybe 10 north of 10
million in revenue this year completely
bootstrap
started it because he used to monetize
so he was like 23 years old
and he cole emailed pomp and said listen
to this podcast i'm working on come to
this event just like he was just like
constantly emailing him pop pop who's
this big bitcoin guy but who was less of
a big bitcoin
guy years ago said all right you've been
emailing me too much
whatever you're persistent i'm thinking
about launching this podcast
i need help launching it and monetizing
it do you want to help this kid
who was a kid at the time said yes and
then eventually launches a
crypto media company called block works
he launches it three or four years ago
it's only an llc so he completely owns
it it's not like it didn't raise any
money
really fascinating business very simple
and he just picked the right category
and now they're doing conferences it's a
slick looking website right
yeah you go to it it looks like
bloomberg or something you know it looks
like a proper you know it just looks
like a template of a good news site
in general and so i think he's like the
subscriber base to this right so like is
this done through email or done through
direct site visits
they make a lot of money through email
and then they have podcasts
so so there's and then they have
conferences and so they have a
conference
for what it's worth showing them close
to half a million visits a month
yeah so it's not it's probably that's
like if you look at our
uh traffic the hustle.com maybe we were
uh two times that and i know that we had
eight hundred thousand to a million a
month
right and um and we had talked about
coin market cap recently which was
uh probably the bigger player in this
space so coin market cap
sold to uh finance i think
and how much they sell for was like
hundreds of millions right five hundreds
of millions
if it didn't sell for that it's worth
that and the shocking thing was that
coin market cap had like a larger
monthly traffic volume than i think the
new york times or
wall street journal i think it was uh
which just shows you like
the level of interest like when we
talked we joked about this we were like
oh like
how do we make this podcast grow and i
was like pivot to crypto there's just
like this insane appetite for crypto
content because
people get in they think they're going
to get rich and every day there's a news
cycle of like the world the world is you
know we're going to the moon or the
world is crashing and like
what's going on and so crypto was a
phenomenal
um place to go so i like block works i
want to share one thing but did you have
something else on block where she was
here
i have a topic related to block works no
he it's just an interesting business i
just thought it was interesting it's
just not
how big look at their about page it
looks like they have 20 people on board
um i don't know who's full time and
who's not full-time but and then if you
click their podcast they have like 12
podcasts
it's like a type of company where uh you
it it is sexy
in that like it's a media company for
crypto i mean that's definitely sexy
but the guy is he's 27 but he runs it
just like a small business where he just
he just slowly adds and adds
hats and i think it's really fascinating
i think they're i think if i had a bet
and i don't have uh i just got to know
him and i don't we didn't even talk
about this if i had a bet i
i would imagine you're going to see this
company sell for in the 40 to 50 million
range in the next 18 months and i just
wanted to bring it up now to call it out
uh about like see it before it actually
happens right
i would take the over on that i think
it's gonna sell for more if the numbers
you're saying or what it is just looking
at it i think
um traditional media companies don't
sell for that much if it's only
i don't know what the revenue is exactly
but it's in the range of 10 million if
it only if they only do let's say 9
million in revenue that's probably only
worth 25 million dollars
you're not putting the crypto premium
right so so companies sell
based on their story and i think the
story here is going to be that
hey look this is where this is where
financial news is going financial news
being probably the biggest kind of most
valuable segment of the news
uh not biggest in terms of popularity
but most valuable per per user right so
the wall street journal
um you know it's a very valuable
publication because every one of their
users is interesting and interested in
investing
somewhere between thousands or millions
of dollars and so
i think if your crypto if you're the
crypto bloomberger the crypto wall
street journal
um like we saw that coin market cap sold
for several hundreds of millions
not necessarily because their revenue
was that much higher but because a big
exchange wanted to grow
and exchanges are worth like coinbase is
worth 80 80 to 100 billion dollars so
uh binance similar like these company
the exchanges are so big they were like
great we need a media arm
right this trend we've been talking
about hubspot oh we want a media arm
robin hood we want a media arm and so
they've been buying up media companies
in order to own their own
media arm which is basically cheap user
acquisition for them and so whether it's
them or it's a traditional media company
that will buy
i don't know but i do think that a
crypto news site is going to get
whatever whatever a normal media site
would sell for
i'd put a two and a half x on it for for
crypto right now because it could be
i wouldn't doubt it and and what i told
him is what i would tell the audience as
well which is
sell to a tech company don't sell to a
media company if you want to create a
media company
build it in hopes of selling to a tech
sam's like make a list of enterprise sas
companies
then it's just like them and take an all
stock deal
all right now now you have set yourself
up no i'm just saying like
do you think that a media company is
going to 3x in market cap value
like pretty quickly or do you think that
coinbase will i think
you would much rather go there right but
yeah i would rather own 50 million
dollars of coinbase stock than i would
have ca
uh of uh new york times stock
right right um another sort of related
thing on this so
i was thinking back i was doing some
reflection uh yesterday actually
i was thinking about uh crypto and i
don't know if i've told you the story
but basically very early on
uh my crypto story was like this we were
at lunch at the
uh i was running an idea lab so that's a
good position to be in when new things
happen
running an idea lab you got a bunch of
engineers and designers you already have
funding
and you're ready to take a new idea and
just chase the market
so bitcoin i think at that time had its
first kind of pop from like the seven
dollar range to like
i don't know what it was 20 bucks and
then 100 bucks and it was all happening
within a period of like one or two
months
uh that that first bike happened then it
came crashing down after 100 back to
like
17 or something like that exact numbers
are wrong but ballpark
bitcoin is very cheap back then and our
um
our sis admin guy pete uh who's like
kind of like a
very early internet guy like would hang
out all day at work he'd be in the irc
channels not slack
and he's talking to other sis admins at
other companies and [__] like that
and these guys like and he was always
like a security like he was always like
ah these big companies are tracking us
and like
you know he's the kind of guy that would
use duckduckgo early on type of thing
and so he was like in the right
community for something like bitcoin and
so he starts telling us
he's like oh bitcoin bitcoin's amazing
dude we're mining he's like mining it on
our servers in the office
he's like yeah it's great i love bitcoin
and we're like ah here's pete you know
pete who's kind of like a like a more
like a neckbeard archetype right he's
like oh pete's you know really into some
something again great yeah so what's he
worth now
well i didn't take it too seriously but
i think he was more like a lot of people
who early on they weren't
putting a ton of like cash into it they
were mining it or they were like
earning it for doing a job and then
spending it because they were like
wanted to be a part of this new economy
uh by the way have you ever heard that
story about andreas antonopoulos
do you know who that guy is no oh
maybe is he the guy who looks like is he
greek
he i think he's greek yeah based on the
name but he's basically um
he was like the bitcoin evangelist so he
was just when bitcoin came out he was
going and talking everywhere just
talking i know who he is as a person
bitcoin's amazing he wrote this bitcoin
book it's great and so anyways he's
given like
he's spread the gospel he's like what
you need when you have a new movement
it's like
this guy was out he was i don't know
much about the bible but like you know
he wasn't jesus but he's like you know
paul or whoever was you know taking the
gospel and going to spreading it
and so he um he'd been doing this for
years
and he had been earning any money he had
he would only take in bitcoin and then
he would spend it on his rent and he
would spend it on his coffee
he wanted to live in crypto and live
what he was preaching
that this new financial system with real
kind of like hard money true money
uh sound money as they say is is the is
the way to go
and so anyways bitcoin price keeps going
up up and up and people are like oh
andreas you must be like a millionaire
100 times over by now no and he's like
well no like i was living off bitcoin i
was spending it like i was
like i was earning it for talking at
some things but i didn't charge a ton
because i just wanted to get the word
out
he's like and then when i had it i was
using it to pay rent and i have a family
and like no i actually
i i actually didn't have a ton well he
wasn't saying it like you know
pity me he was just like you know
contrary to belief popular belief here's
the case
and so there's this guy on um on twitter
friend's name he's like this famous guy
who
he forked bitcoin and like has his uh he
owns bitcoin.com
he's kind of like this he's not very
well liked in the bitcoin ecosystem
roger
van roger vera or something like that is
his name so he starts making fun of
andreas on twitter he's like oh my god
the biggest bitcoin like you know like
uh
carnival barker for all these years
didn't even make money
when bitcoin shot up in price to
thousands of dollars per coin like
like what a joke uh like like nice one
schmuck he starts making fun of him
and then the bitcoin community rallied
and overnight
donated anonymously to his wallet and
made made andreas a millionaire in
bitcoin
overnight um of people people donating
money because they were like no i got
into it because of this guy
he's getting made fun of because he
didn't profit off of this like [__] that
uh so i thought that was like a pretty
cool moment like one of the cool parts
not the like annoying part anyways back
to my story
i'm uh i'm in the idea lab and basically
my cto catches the bug too and he starts
saying
he's like yeah fiat is trash i'm like
what is fiat a car like what are you
talking about
and he's like fiat currency that means
currency that you know the government
makes up and prints like
by there by their fiat they create this
currency he's like it's bad i'm like
well
okay why like the dollar seems fine and
he's like yeah it's fine till it's not
fine look at the history and he starts
telling me about this this
i'm like yeah but that's like ancient
history he's like just yesterday
japan announced that they're going to
double the money supply in the next 10
years
i was like that can't be good right he's
like yeah that's massive dilution that's
like if you just
doubled the shares in this company right
now i would be pissed and he's like
he's like so he's like we should do
something i'm like okay paul like run
with it what's the idea
normally paul was the guy i would give
directions to he's not the ideal guy
he's like tell me what to build i'll
build it i can build anything
and in this case he's like mocking up a
website and he's based like
crypto doesn't have any of the basic
like financial instruments that
uh that the normal economy has so all we
got to do is just build either an
exchange
or a like kind of like a maybe like an
ach protocol or like
a place to deposit in a savings account
like we just need something like that
for crypto
so he mocks it up we start going with it
and uh
our ideal lab was backed by this couple
michael and sochi burch which makes an
individual couple who's
you know independently very wealthy and
so he come michael comes by for lunch
the next day he's like hey the lawyer
like our lawyer susan told us that
you're uh you're doing like a bitcoin
project and i was like yeah
kind of exciting like and i don't really
know it myself i wasn't the one with
conviction it was like
my team and i was just backing them and
so he's asking me he's like isn't that
like
like kind of like for the silk road and
like isn't that like kind of scammy
and i was like no i think there's merit
to it but i couldn't like make a strong
case
he's like dude i don't know man like if
we do something wrong here the financial
space like
look if we if we make a social app that
fails whatever i burned
a million dollars of funding if we do
something that's illegal the sec comes
after us i can lose everything so like
let's put the kibosh on uh on our crypto
exchange that you guys are trying to
like create like launch tomorrow and i
was like ah [__] so i go tell the team
and blah blah and we
long story short we do nothing so we
don't launch the thing
i don't buy any bitcoin at that time
when bitcoin's like under 100
um and we we move on with our life and
then like now years later i'm just
chasing that you know
crypto dream the whole time buying it at
like you know twenty thousand dollars a
coin instead of when it was at 20.
and i was thinking back on it i was like
what was the right move there and i said
i'll kind of lay out my thinking here
i think the right move and i think many
people will come into these situations
where a new trend happens and you're
you know you want to chase it but there
may be risks associated with why you
should or shouldn't do it
and um here's kind of like my my
revisionist thinking you tell me
if you tell me actually i'll pause there
tell me what you think i should have
done in that situation did i make the
right move or what could i have done
differently
because i think it's important to kind
of learn from our game film as
entrepreneurs
well so like objectively you made the
wrong move in that you
you didn't we know what the right move
was now
but looking back knowing what you knew
being who you are
i would say i wouldn't say you made the
right move but i would say you didn't do
anything wrong
right okay so fair enough so let's say
uh
door one is do nothing always right so
do nothing that's what that's the one we
ended up taking
door two was create and launch this kind
of crypto exchange slash money transit
or
whatever that was like where we were
headed what i think was i should have
looked at what does door three four and
five look like so the first thing i
should have done is i should have bought
the currency
right um that's kind of an obvious one
if you believe in this thing enough to
build a startup around it
you should own some of the underlying
asset um
as as something you want so that was
like the first part second was
when i got pushback from somebody richer
smarter and more experienced than me
and i didn't have the answer the answer
shouldn't have been okay no
okay i'll stop it it should have been
well
let's let me put together a case for
doing this give me a week
to put together a case of why we might
do this why this might not be such a bad
idea i agree with your logic
let me put together a case and let's
start with that and so i could have took
a pause breath and i could have said all
right let me go and
actually like get to conviction myself
and if i have conviction i'll convince
anybody in the world
to do that we should do this but if i
don't have conviction it's just a matter
of i haven't really thought this through
enough
and the third option was or the next
option was
what are the other things you could have
done so what are the no risk ways to
ride this wave
that's what i think block works did
that's what coindesk did that's what
coin market cap did
so there was other things you could have
done you could have created a media
company that said all right i'm not
gonna like
try to be a financial exchange and that
has some risks
but why don't we spin up a media side
well there's going to be if this is
going to be a thing people are going to
be interested in the content
we could build that and then that gives
us options to launch more stuff
so that would have been a smart move
that was zero risk um
financially as far as like the the sort
of regulations and sec goes
but still would have been writing that
way i didn't think about that because i
didn't have all these other business
models in my
tool belt of like what else i could do
another would have been to
instead of just launching like a media
company it could have been an agency so
we have several friends like andrew from
uh meta lab uh our friend greg who
launched late checkout
you can launch agencies that help big
companies understand what to do with
this thing
and you can actually charge a [__] ton
of money to do this consensus is the big
one right now that's the big kind of
consultancy for this
i think they do over 100 million dollars
yeah we talked about them they're here
to multi-billion
yeah right just from just from this just
from consulting with big companies
saying hey
do you know how to spell blockchain we
can we can spell it for you and so
um so basically there was other business
models i could have done so looking back
i would say that that's one learning i
had and i guess like
going forward that's i think it's
important when these like
new waves come out to like dive in on
them
learn about them and then think about
all right should i try to build the big
risky thing
should i try to build a community should
i try to build a media site should i try
to build an agency
like i have 10 options and depending on
my level of conviction
um i can go in either one of those
directions i can build the audience
first i can build the technology first i
can try to
land grab and do something there we
could have created our own currency
there was
10 other ideas that we could have done
but anyways this is like a
but to continue talking about that
strategies it is to continue talking
about strategies my opinion is that you
should actually take door number one
in most cases and yeah
and when you see something that you
think is like this is one
life strategy and i think this is a good
strategy you say no to most everything
then when you see the thing that you're
like this is it you go
100 all in on it um
and and so there's a few examples of
this so
and and when you go all in on it it's a
high risk but it's high reward type of
thing so
examples are you become buzzfeed and
facebook gets popular you launch an
entire
media company buzzfeed cheddar did this
as well they launched an entire media
company off facebook live and they sold
for 200 million dollars
now you have loads of examples of
it not working for people more examples
of it not working than it does does work
right um but when you when you spot
these waves i actually think that uh
like the the the risk versus reward is
far in your favor of doing it
and bitcoin is one of those where of
course we know now you know you didn't
know that
what what are the hallmarks of a wave
all right what were some recent waves
and then what how do you know when it's
a wave versus just
shiny object distraction i think
engagement for sure
so i think it's it's not the wave is not
how many people are using it
but the few people who are using it how
much are they using it
right and so does this feel like a cult
do these people seem crazy
uh that's actually a very positive signs
for waves
yes i think that's the the biggest one
is uh are people
like how into it are they so like i was
just talking to a guy that was selling
um
who did a multi-level marketing scheme
where and he didn't know it at the time
but he was
he thought it was multi-level but it was
a pyramid scheme he was like well i'm
just like a sales person
for this energy drink he was a
participant in it yeah yeah yeah and he
was like but i loved it and i thought it
was okay it goes and then it took me
forever to realize that it was a pyramid
scheme and then i was like scamming
people so i had a bail
but for a long time i was so into it and
like when you see like people who are so
into something
like amway like herbalife they actually
become huge huge companies
even if most people don't get it you
don't you only need a few people that
are passionate about it so it's all
about engagement
yeah i would say that so i was like what
are you gonna look for with the wave
second one is
complete behavior change so like
facebook early on was a good example of
this where all of a sudden people were
checking something
like 30 times a day there really weren't
websites that you would go check 30
times a day
and uh facebook was one and so similarly
like
fortnight or twitch something like that
it's like wait you're just streaming a
webcam of yourself for eight hours like
playing video games it's like yeah not a
lot of people do it but the people who
were doing it were doing this completely
weird behavior
that made no sense and had no like real
parallels to what people were what that
same person was doing before
and so if it's been able to consume this
person's life and change their whole
like workflow
then it's going to do that for other
people right like uh remote work
is like that in a small way but that's
that's another one
a third one is go ahead the third one is
just a technology wave so
a new device comes out that can do
something that the other devices
couldn't
like oh this is a phone it has an
accelerometer in it and a gps
so now what what can you create when you
have a gps in your pocket
well you can push a button and someone
could come find you and pick you up and
take you somewhere else
using that same gps and so like you know
ridechair became enabled because
this new device was there or you have a
camera in your pocket at all times
well then i guess people are going to
take way more photos than they were
before
all right that's when you get instagram
you get snapchat so i think the
technology wave is the other one
yeah there's a bunch of these and and
and it's actually fun to talk about like
we all know what the waves are but there
let's talk about some of the waves that
we've seen recently that actually turn
out not to be waves
um or likely won't be waves clubhouse is
one of them
um a lot of people dedicated a lot of
stuff to him i could have seen a startup
raise money on top of
uh a clubhouse show or something like
that right um
and but but but i don't actually hate
people taking that shot and i think that
a lot of people do right
and i think i think you have to measure
how much do you have to lose like for
example in that scenario i was talking
about
i would have launched the crypto thing
because i had nothing to lose our
investor who's like basically a
billionaire is like hey
you know what i don't mind if you fail
on the startup but like
don't have the sec come after me like
that doesn't seem good
let's not hold like a if this works
we're gonna have like a hundred million
dollars of user deposits that we're like
on the hook for that sounds bad i don't
you know i i it wasn't easy to get this
billion dollars i don't want to lose
that so
for him it was the correct decision to
say let's not risk ruin
when you're you know you have nothing
well you have nothing to lose and so
feel free to go more all in and take
more risks faster and if hey if
clubhouse turns out to be a dud
what'd you lose six months of your life
you know like two thousand dollars it's
okay
so since we're talking about reflection
and stuff let me tell you a quick story
so i'm gonna send you this guy's
linkedin i met this guy this week
so i like just last week we were off i
was off
so i just went and hung out with people
my friend joe introduced me to this guy
named val
i don't even know how to say his last
name um but val i went out to lunch with
this guy named val
so this guy's story is basically he came
from
a soviet union country i forget he came
from soviet union i forget what it's
called now the
area that he was from ubekistan is what
he's from he's a
uh like a jewish immigrant from
ubekistan he at the age of 18
listen to this he started a cellphone
ringtone business he was the only
employee
and it did 10 million in revenue in year
three
he was started when he was 18. so this
is when he was like 21. 10 million so 10
million in profit he said he goes based
on the ringtones to americans
yeah he goes i was the only employee oh
i care from
where i don't know what you said
uzbekistan uzbekistan i believe
selling 10 million dollars worth of
ringtones to stupid americans
isn't that beautiful i love that and
that amer uh amazing
um i believe it's called uh you can
scroll down it's called tone media
uh i believe that's what it is um on his
linkedin something like that or tone
fuse i don't i don't even
know which one it is you get so many of
them and the reason why this guy
interests me is so i'm gonna tell you
everything that he has done since but
it's all been bootstrapped no
outside funding and all in different
industries so the first one
um he probably has more but these are
the ones he told me about so uh a
phone business the ringtone business
he's he's like the revenue and he goes
by the way revenue and profits are
pretty much the same thing because i was
the only employee
he was like it went like 2 million 4
million
like 10 and then i sold it and his
second thing was called mobile fuse
which is a ad tech company
uh it's that's boring that's not that
exciting but it's a big business
something like i imagine he didn't tell
me but i imagine like 50 60 million in
revenue pretty big
then uh while he was getting that
started he noticed that peer-to-peer
lending was popular
so things like you know sofi yep stuff
like that
so he created a company called prime
meridian capital i've never even heard
of it
but i think their url might be poised
lending
basically at this point they've given
out billions of peer-to-peer loans
so totally different from ad marketing
or ad tech
then from there he started a uh
a thing called i don't even know how to
pronounce this chicalo
but he was telling me all about this but
basically a company like zales have you
you know zales
or do you know uh jake kay jewelers
jared ernest jones peoples there's a
bunch of them so it's all owned by this
company called cignet
cignet is a multi-billion dollar diamond
business and what they do is they own
all these brands
and he was telling me he was like i was
thinking about what makes that company
special and he was like basically they
have this headquarters where they just
look at which
diamonds are most popular uh which which
brands and which
cuts are selling the best and how can we
tell all of our brands what we think are
gonna be the next big thing
how can we help you optimize that brand
by selling a little bit more efficiently
how can we
buy in bulk things like that so it was
basically it was just a normal mom and
pop store
but we just multiplied it by however
many and so we just created these
these this trends bit and then this
economies that scale you know buying in
bulk stuff
not particularly special but but just
executed really well
and so he goes is well you know i'm
going to build software so i'm going to
help all the mom and pop jewelers do
that same thing
and so we went and started this new
company and if you look at his linkedin
and go to the website you can see it
looks like really janky really simple
um but they uh what they do is a mom and
pop brand can sign up
and they'll the the the the the name of
the company i think it's called
i don't even know how to pronounce it
it's a horrible name how do you say that
jocalio
jocalio it's yeah it's really bad uh so
jacalio will help you get bulk discounts
but then we'll help you uh
spend your marketing so it's almost a
little bit like part agency part buying
in bulk
part um crm where you could like look at
sales and like
help predict which is going to be the
most popular in order in bulk and
i believe this company is going to be
doing around
80 or so million in revenue um wow
and so this freaking guy will have to
like he's he
he he's english as a as a second
language and he's real quiet and he's
real understated
very low key and he was just telling me
all about this and
i had a few learnings the first is just
it's crazy the story i haven't done [__]
in my life
the second this guy's a [__] beast
third
yes he it just and he didn't he's not
flashy i mean he had a nice watch on but
he had normal clothes and he and he
didn't brag about himself i had a pull
i pulled it out of him and he um
a few things what we tell ourselves
about why we can't do something
it's [__] it's mostly [__] i
mean some people are more talented than
others
but you could just get so much done just
by just by working really hard so what
we tell ourselves about
why we can't do blank that's nonsense
second there's this
i don't know like some people call it
like the i think it's called the red
pill
i forget what people call it where they
like see the world differently i've hung
out with enough people that just crush
it and a lot of people who you don't
never even heard of
and i'm in it and oftentimes i'll like
when i'm looking at this house i'm like
oh should i buy this lot i got to sink
this money into it it's going to fail
but there's so many there's a few people
in this world and i know a lot of these
people
who just be like yeah of course just
let's do it and they're just so
confident i actually think you have a
little bit of that in you um they're
just so
confident and they default to optimism
optimism
and it works so well it's like this this
ability
in this case it's money but it could be
anything it could be um you know well
we're just gonna fly there and we're
just going to figure it out
but this is like default to yeah
of course it's going to work a few
people have that and that attitude gets
you so far
uh and and i i've been able to
experience that just by being around
some of these people
but it's just a really fascinating
person wow i love this uh i love that
little story i love this guy this is
extreme this is really cool and uh
yeah i'm impressed i love meeting these
kind of like under the radar
you know self-made kind of like business
badasses that have hopped from industry
to industry it's like
there's zero luck involved when you're
going to do that right there's
luck is luck is a like kind of a scalar
it's like a multiple of like
the thing was successful whether
ringtones were going to be worth 10
million or 20 million or 50 million of
1 million it was hard to say but if
you're the type person that's going to
make the ringtone business the mobile ad
business the
jewelry like independent business the
whatever uh the
the peer-to-peer lending company um you
have you know the track record speaks
for itself you know what you're doing as
far as like identifying an opportunity
and then chasing it properly
and i just googled this guy uh i it
looks like he has a twitter but
like no followers and he has 200
followers on instagram and he posts
pictures of his vacation with his family
like nothing sexy i mean yeah he's got
actually some fancy cars that's sexy but
i guess this whole point of like you get
caught in this bubble of you have to
build an audience
no you don't yeah no you don't you don't
you don't you can and maybe that could
be fun for you you don't
you could do something that no one has
ever heard of you you could just cold
call and you could get done with it
likely whatever you want to get done and
another thing that i've learned is just
intensity
so this idea of well you have this
ringtone business that's
kind of silly it's like yeah maybe but i
bet you like
i mean it could make 10 million dollars
a year which is like crazy
rich um and just like stepping it up
on the stepping up on the amp it up
format on the intensity idea
so i was working out this morning um
with the guy whose house i'm in and so
he was like hey
like i don't know if you're up but like
trainer's coming at 8 a.m if you want to
get a workout in
yeah fantastic i'm up let's do it so i
go downstairs
home gym crazy go inside trainer's there
we're doing our thing
and um and i don't particularly work out
i'm not like a
super intense workout guy like i'm
trying to do well but like
my default is like i i feel the way most
people feel in the workout like i'm
getting
super tired i'm like my muscles are
failing like they're not i don't feel
like i could do that anymore you know
like i'm trying
oh like if she's like all right how much
you want to squat i'm like well
i don't really know and uh all right
let's start with like a little bit and
then like let's go
up from there i'm not like trying to
like prove something every second of
the workout but he was talking about um
intensity during the workout he's a very
intense guy
and so he uh um at the end we were doing
abs just to finish and so we're doing
like a russian twist
thing or whatever he's facing the other
direction he's doing the other ab
workout
and we're just taking turns i'm doing
mine he's doing his i'm doing the
russian twist
and he heard me ask the trainer i go
should i have my legs in the air she's
like yeah that makes a bit harder and i
was like okay cool let me try
and so i was just doing it um it was
just kind of like an offhand comment
and then when it was his turn to go to
that it was like the second round second
set
he's like i gotta i gotta put my legs up
now and she's like no no you don't have
to you can just put it down he's like no
if he's gonna do it then i gotta do it
and he's like he's like that's the best
part about working out with somebody
is that their intensity picks you up and
if you pick the right partner
then you match their intensity and you
just get that little extra that you're
working again if you're on your own he's
like that's the best part
and i think that's what this podcast is
for a lot of people is
we are like their workout buddy for
their like kind of like the brain
workout basically of just thinking about
businesses being excited about things
learning new [__]
and so i think that's the benefit we're
giving some people
through this podcast but it's also what
um what like when you go meet this guy
and you you know what's the benefit of
being this guy you're not gonna do a
deal with him you're not gonna invest in
his company
but literally just having met him and
heard his story
all of a sudden now you you can you got
red pill you're gonna see the world
differently
just because you know that he exists and
when we tell his story now hundreds of
thousands of other people listening to
this are gonna know that he exists
i think that's really cool and i think
it's something you should be intentional
about of getting around other people
so that you have those red pill moments
and you get around other people's
intensity so you raise your game
so let me give this guy a shout out i'll
spell his name because i don't think i
said his last name
his name is val v-a-l last name
i don't know how to i'm sorry val but uh
anyway that that's his uh that's his
name pretty interesting dude if you
click like contact info all of his
companies are there his emails are on
his linkedin
interesting guy um okay so we're like 45
are we gonna go to ideas are we gonna
are we gonna are we gonna you wanna keep
it to this like little
i don't know what what do you wanna do
with so i have one that i think is gonna
be a good segment
we're gonna finish on that let's finish
strong people are gonna be by the end of
this people are gonna be hyped up all
right so
somebody i think by the way i i think
they will dan are they gonna be hyped on
this
okay very hyped thanks you sounds great
dad is trapped somewhere
dana's trapped inside my computer right
now it sounds like
all right so uh so i want to finish up
with this
idea of uh teenage side hustles so
somebody emailed me
and they said hey you know love the pod
my kid is i think 12 13 years old
they're like i want to get him into
entrepreneurship
my daughter is like 11. my son is 13. i
want them both to
learn about business uh do you have any
ideas
for side hustles or little like kind of
like mini hustles
that a uh a teenager could do and so it
got me thinking and so i started
going down this i thought this would be
a fun brainstorm for us i do have some
ideas that i wrote down for this but
i basically gave it 15 minutes of
thought and i was like okay cool i'll do
this on the pod live
what do you think great you you gotta
kick it off though because
you spent more time thinking about it
and then i will uh i'll come up with a
few while you're talking
all right so here's the teenage side
hustles i break it down into four
categories
so the first one is called blue collar
stuff okay so this is stuff people
teens have been doing for a long time
but with a twist here so
uh local normal blue collar stuff you go
you mow lawns in the neighborhood
you deliver the paper you shovel snow
depending on where you're at
i think that's all cool so here's how i
would step it up so i would
say hey here's one thing we could do
right we're going to provide a service
to our neighbors
but let me teach you in business about
leverage right we don't want to trade
our time for money i don't want to be
the one mowing the lawn i don't want to
be the one shoveling snow so you could
do two things
you could teach them to hire up other
kids and basically
have the other people in the
neighborhood doing the work while you
are doing the sales and
uh you're taking in the money and you're
paying out from there so you could teach
them labor leverage there
the other way of doing this is you have
them
uh learn two things at once so you have
door-to-door sales in your neighborhood
but secondly you teach them about lead
gen so instead of actually having to do
the work all you need to do is make the
sale
um or or get the warm lead even so i was
thinking you could go in a neighborhood
you could go door-to-door so here's my
specific idea for them
go go around your neighborhood and
you're gonna you're gonna knock on the
door and you're gonna sell one of two
things either pest control
um so you're gonna say hey we live in
the neighborhood
you know our house and other houses have
had issues in the past with pests and
infestations
and it's better to catch it early before
it becomes like a major problem and you
have to gut the whole kitchen
because you got this you know mice
infestation or rats or or
cockroaches or whatever and so um would
you be
would you want a free inspection uh
would you be interested in an
inspection to let you know if your house
good condition bad condition or needs
need some work and then basically what
you do is you call up the local
you know pest control service and you
say hey i have
15 houses in my neighborhood that are
interested in getting an inspection
and um and you know i think that even if
10 of them or
20 percent of them convert that you guys
will get some good business out of this
so um i'm calling up local services
local service providers and seeing if
anybody
basically would want to uh want these
leads and i have all their information
for you i did the first first contact
with them i have their name their number
and i have the details about what
they're interested what they're worried
about what they're interested in
and basically i would sell those leads
to a local pest control company
i think you could make good money doing
that just around your neighborhood and
other neighborhoods
and you would learn that hey you know
where is the value capture the value
capture is in
getting the customer not and actually
going and looking under the floorboards
for cockroaches okay so that's the
first first blue collar one the other
part of that oh hold on listen to this
so i'm i'm trying to find there here it
is okay so i i know a guy he spoke at
hustle account his name is gabe gabriel
oona asaseki
so what he did was he he's a friend of
mine uh
he started this company where basically
uh
they did legion so it was called cal
finder so if you google
california home painting california pest
control you get brought to their website
they just do a better job of displaying
information you submit a lead they send
it to a pink company and that paint
company pays them five dollars for that
email address
the way it started is he bought a yellow
notepad
and he went door to door to find people
who would be interested in having their
home painted
he collected a list of a hundred names
in the first day
and then he sold that for ten thousand
dollars to a
variety different like different pink
paint companies and he did that a couple
more times and then he
eventually created a proper company that
made 20 million dollars a year in sales
so that's the outcome or potential
outcome to that yeah so the downside of
this your kids might start making more
than you do
a year uh but the upside is they'll
learn a lot about business all right so
that's the first one you could do this
with anything pool fencing hey you
notice you have a pool
but you don't have a fence you know it's
against california law to have a fence
without a pool when you have kids
um you know would you like us to come
out and give you an estimate of how much
that would cost to keep it safe
and you know so you could do pool
fencing pest control home painting
whatever doesn't matter um so i so my
specific idea would be
blue collar lead gen that's number one
number two events
so you've hosted conferences and events
i think that you could
if you're a teenager i think you could
host a neighborhood fair
here's how this works you go out you
rent the bouncy house the slip and slide
all the stuff that like for one
individual home to do it's kind of an
expensive birthday party
but if you're gonna do it and amortize
it across around across the the cost of
the whole neighborhood
it's actually not a bad idea and so i
would create the neighborhood fair i
would charge for entry
i would uh i would have a local sponsor
you know the local bank would sponsor it
because who could turn down your kids
smile and say hey i'm hosting the
neighborhood fair
would you be a sponsor for us for 500 or
whatever
and uh you know all the proceeds go to
us as kids
you know to fund my own education and so
i would basically rent a bunch of cool
stuff have cotton candy have all the
stuff
charge tickets and uh neighborhood fair
that's my second idea events what do you
think of that one
i think that's okay i would do the first
one over the second one the second one
sounds like a pain in the butt
i'm just giving them options here i'm
giving them options keep swinging
three the theme of this one is little
kids acting like adults
so we've all had the like kind of
fundraiser thing where you you go door
to door and you say hey would you like
to buy you know cookie dough and ice
cream and
wrapping paper for our like school
charity great
so here's my twist on that my twist on
that is that you call it the
the bitcoin junior club or something the
bitcoin kids club
and basically you go door-to-door and
say hey i'm really interested in bitcoin
have you heard about bitcoin
yeah i've heard of bitcoin well hey the
neighborhood we want to create
we uh you know two of us three of us
kids in the neighborhood
we were creating the first kids bitcoin
club
and what we want is uh for every house
to invest
somewhere between you know about a
hundred dollars and we're gonna buy
bitcoin and you're gonna own it and
we're gonna take a management fee on top
of what we
of of the of managing the money right so
we're going to create a little
investment club we want to learn about
finance and money
this is a great way for us to do it and
for you you'll be owning bitcoin
we're going to help you out we're going
to teach you all about it we're going to
give a presentation at the end
um and you know hey if your kid wants to
be involved in the club they can too
and so i would create this little and i
would create a small little money
management fund
and i would try to get houses to give me
you know a thousand bucks if they can
depending on your neighborhood
this is either impossible or it'll be
easy and
i would go to the rich neighborhoods and
i would say that's what we're doing and
for them they actually get to own an
asset so it's not like they're just
giving away the money they're actually
going to get the asset
but you're going to charge you know
you're well instead of a normal two
percent fee we're going to call it a 10
fee that you're going to take in
exchange for managing money and then
you're going to send out a newsletter
of the report about what's going on in
bitcoin i think it's awesome i think
that it's just like
yes this is an easy yeah it's just it's
cute enough that it justifies
sending your kid to hang out with people
exactly okay so those are three ideas
the way i was thinking about this and
this is another piece is like
how do you even brainstorm this so when
i brainstorm
i don't think about what's the idea
right i'll think about two things so the
first thing i thought of was
what do i remember from my childhood and
then what's the 20 twist i could put on
this right so that's the fundraising
idea but the twist is now it's for
bitcoin
right or uh i used to mow lawns but the
twist is actually i'm going to like sell
those leads to a
lawn mowing service that's the first way
i think about things what do i already
know
that i can just put a 20 twist on to
make it fit this situation
the second thing is i don't look for
answers when i brainstorm i look for
questions so here's the questions i
wrote down before i brainstormed this i
said
what's cute when a kid does it but
annoying if an adult did it
that's a great i started brainstorming
ideas right the second one is
what's fun for kids but boring for
adults like you know my daughter she
loves like cleaning
like if i let her clean she'll clean a
folding she loves to fold
uh kids actually like i used to have a
lot of fun mowing lawns but like as an
adult i hate to go mold on my lawn now
and so if i know something that's fun
for a kid boring for an adult we can
have them do it
the next one is what are kids actually
just good at that adults are bad at
so there's just things that kids are
just better at okay what are those and
lastly
what amount of money is a win for a kid
but would not be a win for an adult
because then the kid can do it and they
would be happy with it
but no an adult won't do it because this
is not enough
money there for the to fill the void of
what they're looking for at the
opportunity cost
and so that's how i brainstormed this so
that's just a little peek
under the hood about how to think about
stuff like this is don't
answer look ask a bunch of questions and
then spitball if i
for my kid i would probably have them i
would think of what skill should they
learn now that they won't have time to
learn in the future
so uh for for them that will have big
impact for them i think it would be
door i think door-to-door and i would
sell
i would send them to it like a an amco
or i think it's sorry cut co or some
type of like
door-to-door knife or door-to-door books
some type of
cutthroat time where it's like look
you're gonna spend three months for two
two different summers in a row you're
gonna do this you're not gonna like it
at first
but the skill that you learn you're
never gonna be able to learn this
again like this in your life and it's
gonna it'll it'll change your world
if you can get this yeah exactly we're
not going to baseball camp
we're going to cutco camp you're going
to learn how to sell knives door to door
this summer that's what happens
what i'm going to do that i think that
would be the right move
yeah anyway so those are my teenage side
hustles to like i forgot the person who
wrote in to whoever wrote in
that's my answer sorry i haven't emailed
you dan what do you think
did we we meandered a little bit yeah i
really liked the end
i used to sell calendars in high school
door-to-door
got a friend by the way another
my brain's still firing on ideas here's
another one digitize the neighborhood's
home videos everybody
i know who's like kind of like my
parents age they have a bunch of
photos and albums and videos on like
little cassettes that's a great business
they're worried that those are all gonna
go away and you just say hey i'm gonna
drop this box off in front of every door
and i'm just going to put a sticker on
it
and i'm going to say put your put your
photos and videos here in here
i'm going to give it back to you you
know sort of i'm going to send you
it i'll put it in the cloud for you so
you'll have these forever in good
quality and you never have to worry
about these going bad or losing this box
or
water spilling on it or anything like
that let's let's save your memories
i think everything is one that's the the
g that's incredibly smart because you
don't need to be that good
at doing it you just have to have time
yeah exactly we could basically just go
drive it to like costco or whoever does
this but or you could do it yourself
um i don't know if it's costco but like
some of these yeah
one of the retailers they do this
they'll digitize that's a great service
to offer uh
offer because your time is free yeah
right i would that's a good one
that's what i would do i would pick that
one um all right i guess that's the
episode
we'll see what people think of that i
thought it was actually quite good i
enjoy hearing stories
uh love people so we'll see if it's good
yeah let us know uh tweet it sam he's
the sampara on twitter tweet at me i'm
sean vp
and uh let us know what you think of the
episodes we take that feedback and
that's how we adjust
a little less randomness a little less
life advice a little more ideas a little
more
stories about wealthy people whatever
you guys want so let us know
how you want us to shift it
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days off on
the road less travel never looking back